Diane (offscreen): Filming.
T: That's his life- Oh hey. G: Oh!
G: Hi guys, we're here with Tyler Oakley.
T: *Ba ding*
G: Oh, he does some sound effects.
T: You will be venmoed.
So we shot a video over on Tyler's channel where I got to live out my dreams of being Cindy Lou Who and Tyler...
T: I grinched it the f**k out.
G: So make sure you go over on his channel and watch that because we played the humming challenge
to figure out Christmas songs and I thought staying in the festive spirit,
we would play a little game of 'Never Have I Ever' to find out who's been on the naughty list this year and-
T: There it is.
T: I was like where's the connection?
G: Where is it going to connect. T: She made it.
G: I tweeted out for you guys to send us 'Never Have I Ever' questions.
Diane has collected them in this beautiful hat.
T: I gasped.
G: So we have a bunch of questions that I haven't even seen in here,
and we're gonna go back and forth and play 'Never Have I Ever'.
T: So do you hold up ten fingers or five fingers or?
T: What's the deal?
G: So, theres a-
Diane (offscreen): So you lose fingers.
G: Yeah, basically there is a bunch of different-
G: We're gonna play where you hold up five fingers, and basically the question gets asked,
and if you have done what the question is asking, you lose a finger.
G: Because that means you're naughty.
T: I recently was grinding with a guy with only four fingers and I found out while we were holding hands,
and I was grinding with him.
T: And I was like there's nothing wrong with having nine fingers,
but I was like am I really f**ked up.
There's no subtle way to be like-
1...2...3...4.
T: So anyway... Let's lose some fingers.
G: Okay, let's begin we start with five and we see who's gonna be the naughtiest first.
Did you just check your own fingernails?
T: I was checking my nails.
G: I'll start off. Okay.
T: This is the first one I'm putting down, people don't need to see that.
G: Meaning like- I broke up with someone and they-
T: I'm no homewrecker. G: No, I-
T: Have you ever like exposed somebody's boyfriend to them and be like
listen I need to tell you the truth about your
terrible boyfriend or husband.
G: No. Thank God. I haven't. I think I'm clear on this.
T: I think we sustained.
G: We're nice. We're still nice.
T: We still have our fingers.
G: A three-person relationship.
T: It's fun getting into throuple...
T: That's the-
G: I'm like looking at your fingers like none of them are going down.
T: No, I have not been in a throuple.
G: I haven't been in a throuple.
T: And that's like you- that's not a threesome.
G: No, it's a relationship based-
three party activity. T: Yes, feelings,
emotions.
G: Yeah, where you all want to be there together. No. I can't do that. T: No,
T: I have not.
G: I'm so selfish.
G: Bye! T: Bye.
(laughs)
T: Me and Grace Helbig, hello...
G: Secret's out.
T: Oh sh*t, wait.
T: There we go. That's a hard one.
G: I have not.
T: Will you define the mile-high club?
G: Having sex in a plane, that you're a mile above the ground at least.
G: You have sexual relations-
T: What about the good sis Kilimanjaro?
G: Oh like, on the mountain top, cause I've done that.
T: No, you have not!
G: I have hooked up on top of a mountain, yeah.
T: On Kilimanjaro?
G: No, not Kilimanjaro.
G: But I don't think that counts. Technically the mile-high club is in a plane,
which seems so hard to do.
T: Oh I have.
G: Yeah, big time.
T: And I also love you.
G: And I'm basically calling you an asshole right now.
T: No!
G: I don't know what the time frame is on when someone gets alerted when you've liked their photo.
T: They get it right away.
G: Really?
T: Technology.
G: Who knew?
T: I don't even mind-
T: I'll go like two years deep and like four pictures. I want the message to get across.
G: Oh, you're deep-diving.
T: Yes, ma'am Pam!
T: I'm all "Boo-boop"
G: Yeah, in the house that we shot my E show, I did.
T: I've been there!
G: All the plumbing was bad, the toilets got clogged a couple times during the season
and then the last time it got clogged- Cause they
always just blame the crew. So last timr it was me, but I blamed the crew. T: I am-
positive this has happened.
T: So I'm just gonna put a finger down. I don't have a specific answer- G: Right. T: -but lord knows I've done it.
T (scoffs): Well, yeah.
T: Me, flirting: *stutters*.
G: I'm not good at flirting, and to get something for free-
T: Give me your best shot. I've got guacamole, it can be free.
G: I'm good.
G: No, you and Mamrie are the masters of this.
T: What do you mean?
G: No, don't upward inflection me!
G: What's the best free thing that you've gotten from flirting?
T: I don't know specifics.
T: I'm sure like to cut the line like the Apple store, or like to cut the line at Disneyland.
T: I just don't like to wait for things.
G: Yeah, that makes sense.
T: She's a bossy impatient girl.
G: No. T: No, I don't take intimate pictures.
G: No, me either. I'm too paranoid. T: You really shouldn't.
G: No, not at all, especially because people can look at your stuff on your computer and your phone-
G: Why do you think all your ads are tailored exactly to what you're looking up?
T: Retweet. Go off!
G: I've had to have a serious conversation
with someone that thought we were more serious when I met someone else that I was more interested in.
T: I don't think this is a fair question, cause dating is like-
T: Girl, you're dabble in that place, going over here with somebody.
G: Sure.
T: Like serious with two people at once
and you had to like figure it out, because otherwise my finger is going down,
T: I think I'm like a half. I'm a halfsie.
G: No, I have. I have.
T: Bye.
G: Bye.
G: Oh you're done!
T: I'm done.
G: You're done, she's out!
T: Now I'm just a fingerless lady.
G: Well I think all of this-
T: Wait, do-
are you naughty? Yeah.
G: Yeah, we're all naughty, that's what this game is meant to prove, that everyone's naughty.
G: No one's nice, if they're nice, they're lying.
G: The reward is that you guys get to go watch the video that we made over on Tyler's channel.
T: Wow, they're so blessed.
G: You really are, because I, if you noticed in that video, could not look Tyler in the face at all.
T: It was intimate.
G: Go watch Tyler's video, the link will be in the description box below, and go check Tyler out
across all social media platforms just @TylerOakley, right?
T: God bless, and if you're one of my people subscribe to Grace and like this video
and comment with something very sweet.
G: Oh!
T: I think something sweet would be nice.
G: Sure, I was gonna say tell us something naughty you've done to make us feel like humans.
T: Yes, uh, yeah.
(laughs)
T: Okay, cool.
G: Other than that, I don't know.
G: Wait, okay, just for funsies.
G: I want to see what the last ones were.
G: "Never have I ever thought I saw a ghost."
G: I've thought I saw a ghost.
T: No.
G: Ever?
T: Never, I don't believe in that shit.
T: See, if I see something like wickedy wickedy-
I think it's a reflection from the back of my glasses,
and I just let my brain think that. G: Mine is always like 'Oh, there's- the devil lives in my house now.'
G: "Never have I ever wet the bed in my adult life." T: No. G: I- I have.
T: Work.
G: Yeah. Okay, "never have I ever cheated on a test."
T: Oh hell yeah.
G: Yeah, I cheated on my-
T: I was all like, a million little notes on me.
G: That's what my graphing calculator was for. You could write in the slot that it shoved into.
T: I would just peek around.
G: "Never have I ever lied to another friend about where you are because you are with someone they don't like." Yeah.
T: Yeah.
G: I've done that.
T: I'm just here to protect my friends. G: You alright?
T: I am alright.